[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
when Sebastian Payne Whitehall editor of
the financial times and Noah Hoffman
political reporter at the sun though
they both are let's see what's on some
of those front pages for you now
well the eye leads with a warning from
Tori Euro Skeptics to prime minister
Rishi sunak not to strike a Swiss style
trade deal with the EU Switzerland has
access to the single Market but allows
free movement of people and pays money
into the EU
same lead story in the mail with the
headline don't betray us on brexit
the express 2 says there's a fury at any
suggestion the UK may go soft on brexit
Sebastian's paper the financial times
looks at the end of the cop 27 climate
Summit and describes the result as a
Discord even though an agreement was
reached on helping poorer Nations
according to the guardian experts fear
the deal still leaves the world on the
brink of catastrophe
comedian Joe lysett burning 10 000
pounds in cash to protest at the World
Cup being held in Qatar leads the Metro
with the headline wad a waste and he
actually shredded not burned it if it is
real cash that is the star focuses on
the football cheering on the England
Captain Harry Kane
and Noah's paper the sun strikes a
similar note to praising the team as
lions of Arabia
and reminded that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Sebastian Payne Whitehall editor of the
financial times and no Hoffman political
reporter at the sun welcome to both of
you let us start with the sauna Noah
your paper and uh Harry Kane pictured uh
looking at triumphant even before
kicking the first ball tomorrow on the
front of the paper
yeah he is although how long that sort
of feeling of Jubilation and excitement
will last remains to be seen given this
big controversy that's emerged um with
the armband that Harry Kane plans to
wear um it's a one love Rainbow armband
uh reflecting very much strong support
for the lgbtq plus Community who have
really
um suffered in this whole um debacle
with the World Cup being in Qatar Qatar
has an abysmal human rights track record
um homosexuality is illegal there which
is appalling
um in this day and age let alone ever
now uh there could be FIFA officials
actually coming in to tell Harry Kane
that he has to remove the badge and he
could risk even being booked if he
continues to wear it which is the big
story developing this evening now six
other captains have also pledged that
they want to wear the badge the band to
show their support and now it sort of
remains to be seen what happens with
this drama unfolding yes and Sebastian's
it does seem as if they will go ahead
and wear the the armbands regardless of
what sanctions they they might face
and good for them is what I say I think
that obviously this whole world cup
seems a bit of a disaster from start to
finish that if you look at the scenes
from the stadium in Qatar today half the
seats are empty people aren't seem to be
turning up and we saw the controversy of
course over the beer ban as well and
everything you see about it is not
football really as we know it it doesn't
even have much of the joy much of the
togetherness much of the people and sort
of coming together and to celebrate
their national teams because of the
onerous cultural restrictions that
involved with guitar and I think the
whole thing is just pretty shameful for
FIFA really the fact that they went to
guitar in the first place and how it has
been handled and I think the England
team is as it says on the front page or
something is going to where those
armbands I think gout Southgate has said
that the evening team will take the knee
at the beginning of the match which is a
symbol of the black lives matter
movement so I think it's a really good
thing that they're willing to do this
and stand up to it if they get cards
then so be it it's better than just
standing by and letting this stuff go by
and I think there's many other the
people who've gone to Qatar who are
commentating being involved getting paid
large sums of money you need to take a
very hard look at themselves in the
mirror
um would you agree with that that no I
mean
we've decided to to have the games there
that's going ahead
um can you really still criticize people
who are there working commentating being
part of games which have been agreed to
go ahead
I think uh some of the criticisms are
fair but at the same time uh someone
needs to go and do the job if we're
going to participate if england is going
to go and play uh then we need our
English broadcasters there to film it
and to um you know let the country know
what's happening
um but with that being said it is such a
shame that this that we're in this
situation in the first place and I can't
even begin to imagine how LGBT plus
people are feeling how families of those
migrant workers who were just had to
suffer under the most appalling labor
restrictions and workers rights a
feeling too
um so yes I understand the criticism of
people who have gone uh to commentate
there but at the same time somebody did
have to do it um and I have sympathy in
that regard as well Sebastian on the
front of the Metro along the same line
same story Joe lice at shredding ten
thousand pounds in uh cash don't know
whether it's real cash or not but this
is part of his protest
that's right and this is all to do with
um David Beckham because he was
basically saying if David Beckham pulled
out of his role at the World Cup then he
wouldn't be shredding the cash David
Beckham didn't and he traded the cash
and there is some confusion about
whether it was actually 10 000 pounds of
real money there but of course people
beware of Joe lyce up from his uh recent
mocking I think prime minister Liz truss
on the BBC that obviously he is a
comedian who loves to make a big
statement um in a political way about
this so I found that vaguely amusing and
just to come back to Noah's Point
earlier you're obviously right that if
this is going ahead you've got our
people there to um make sure football
fans home can enjoy it whether it's
being filmed or being commentating or
what have you but I do think there was a
hypocrisy from some people particularly
um you know if you think Gary Neville
for example who likes to make a very big
stand about social and political issues
and then yeah it's taking quite large
sums of money to go out there and
commentate so I do think you do have to
call it out when there are people being
hypocritical about this in terms of the
run-up to the World Cup what's your view
Noah um in terms of level of excitement
does it feel like a World Cup to you
so despite not being the biggest
um football mad person on the planet
um I can feel quite a massive difference
in the atmosphere today versus say the
Euros where everybody was so excited you
could see it you could feel it um pubs
were absolutely packed and I know the
England gay man with Iran is still to
happen tomorrow when I speak to Footy
mad friends and journalists and there is
absolutely no repeat of that whatsoever
people say oh we're gonna watch it
because it's England but there's no sort
of feeling that this massive event
that's meant to bring people together
where you're meant to you know
um get the beers Out Come Together cheer
on England none of that's really here
this time and that's a shame
to the male Sebastian the headline don't
betray us on brexit what's the detail of
this story
so this comes originally from a piece in
the Sunday Times today that had
government insiders talking about
essentially a closer trading
relationship with the EU
um and the idea being focused on a Swiss
style relationship where they have um
they're not members of the single Market
or the Customs Union but they're much
more closely integrated in return for
having
um um free movement of people and
abiding by the eu's rules now this is
something that I think people within
Whitehall Within part of the sunat
government are saying well hang on a
minute we might need to do some things
to try and deal with the country's
growth problem and there is no doubt
about it but it has had a bit of a
dampening effect on the UK's growth
Prospect so it's only natural this would
be discussed and if you want the reason
why this is never going to happen then
look at the mail tomorrow and look at
the express as well which is talking
about a brexit betrayal and even though
these people were not talking about
rejoining the block or trying to go back
to where we were in 2016 it's been a big
backlash Lord David Frost who's kind of
the the brexit conscience Tory party
he's been out and about on social media
saying this would be a really bad idea
so it sort of feels to me as if this is
a non-starter but it wouldn't at all
surprised me over the next couple of
years if you do start to see more people
talking about is that begs a deal we've
got now the right one can it be improved
do we want to tweak parts of it and do
we want slightly closer alignment now
I'm not saying it's going to happen
labor party is going to go nowhere near
the next election and like the Tories
were but it is becoming more prominent
in political circles where it would have
been something anathema a couple of
years ago yes no in certain sections
within the conservative party uh
seemingly extremely worried about
seeking closer ties with the EU which is
what it suggested that the prime
minister is trying to do or about to do
well Downing Street categorically denies
any involvement in trying to bring uh
Britain closer to uh the EU and to have
any sort of Swiss style uh relationship
they are shutting that down straight
away with very strong language
um Sochi were sort of behind the scene
insiders that you talk to uh but then
again the Sunday Times Did report that
behind closed doors these conversations
are starting to take root I would just
Echo what Seb uh said earlier there is
no way this is ever going to happen
because it is far too politically toxic
voters won't stand for it brexit voters
won't stand for it
um very very powerful members of the
Tory party powerful MPS that European
research group of more right-wing Ardent
brexiteers are never gonna stand for it
and let's not forget we've just come
from a place uh when Liz trust was Tori
party leader where the conservative
party was so divided and those divisions
were causing so much problems for the
party
um in the polls and you know just being
able to get anything done they don't
want to come back to that place uh when
Rishi sunak has come back uh sorry has
won um the Tory leadership race a lot of
people thought all right let's lay down
our arms let's come together because
this is our last chance this is the
fight for survival now if Richie sunac
was to pursue
um a sort of Swiss star relationship
with the EU that would all go away and
we would see these divisions arise again
and he just won't risk that happening
yeah Nadine Doris quote is saying he
needs to reassure people that brexit is
safe and that the question of commencing
payments to the EU was totally absurd we
are going to take a break there both of
you stay right where you are
coming up Trump's allowed back on
Twitter by popular demand according to
Elon Musk stay with us for more on that
[Music]
welcome back still with me Sebastian
Payne the White Hall editor of the
financial times and Noah Hoffman
political reporter at the sun taking us
through the papers we're going to have a
look at the Metro now and Donald Trump
pictured there alongside Elon Musk who
has allowed him back onto the Twitter
platform Sebastian
yes this is a huge moment both for
Twitter and for politics generally that
obviously Donald Trump was uh banned
permanently for Twitter following the
event of January the 6th the
Insurrection following
um the 2020 presidential election he's
been tweeting on his own platform and
has been appearing on TV as well but
Twitter was always Trump's most
important way of communicating with the
world he mastered the author to be very
clear and carefully and it's been a huge
debate but whether he should be allowed
back on or not because he is a former
president he has a huge following but
also he has used it to spread fake news
and occasionally incite people against
um against democracy so it is
controversial Elon Musk as we know who
took over Twitter and is doing his best
to try and destroy the platform held a
poll it all to me he said Thomas to come
back and he is now back I don't think
he's tweeted it the last time I looked
but I'm sure we're hearing from him very
soon yes he has said that he's unlikely
to start using it again so he'll have
the facility but um he claims that he's
not going to be back on Twitter anytime
soon
so he said that again Sebastian he won't
be able to resist don't trust that when
Paul gets going in the 24 race he will
be tweeting again I'm sure I'm sure
you're probably right on that Noah what
do you think
uh yeah I would agree with Seb I think
one issue with the Trump ban was some
sort of inconsistencies uh at Twitter
before Elon Musk came in and made this
huge mess that Seb was referring to
earlier um and those inconsistencies are
with who gets banned from the platform
so I very much understand the reasons
why Trump was banned but you could apply
those same ones to other figures who are
on the platform but still sort of had
free reign to share
um opinions that one could argue uh our
opinions that were equally um as
dangerous so they hadn't sort of nailed
down the policy that determined you know
when when was it right to de-platform
someone so to speak I think
um the Trump move it was controversial
but understandable in light of January 6
protecting democracy is obviously one of
the most important things uh in the
world and for him to undermine it
undermine it in such a scary and real
way is obviously of great concern but
you do have to have a sort of uh rule
that can apply to everyone and we didn't
really see that before but now with
Trump back uh who knows what will happen
but I assume it will be quite chaotic
but but since his band he has actually
launched his own truth social platform
and he recently said in Las Vegas that
Twitter had a lot of problems predicting
it may make it it may not
um so interesting views there despite
being let back on by Elon Musk let's
have a look at the guardian and their
analysis following cop 27 that there has
been quite momentous still struck but
lots of targets not agreed upon some
Discord with those meeting in in charmel
Sheikh Sebastian
so you can look at this one of two ways
on the one hand this is richer country
saying they're going to help give money
towards poor countries to deal with
climate change and of course many past
the developing world are those who are
going to suffer the most as temperatures
continue to rise but um alak Sharma who
was president of cop 26 when it was in
UK and has handed that over he's been
predisparaging saying um you know a
clear commitment to phaser or fossil
fuels not in this text so that's
something obviously everyone was pushing
for and we saw that at cop26 in Glasgow
where there was a big effort to try and
get China to end its fossil fuel power
stations which is one of the world's
biggest
um carbon emitters so again it's a very
mixed bag and if we're into this
scenario where people are saying oh we
have actually going to try and get
towards limiting climate change to 1.5
degrees Centigrade that's the level that
all International scientists say is
crucial to avoid the worst most
catastrophic outcomes from it and again
as you see with all this there's a lot
of countries a lot of different
priorities and particularly when you've
got the energy Crunch at the moment lot
of people they look at these kind of
summits they look at climate change and
say this is not the priority that's
obviously a mistake because it should be
everyone's priority it's going to affect
all of our lives and our children and
future generations for a long time to
come but yeah so sort of gradual
progress but I think everyone would
agree not really enough yeah and still
saying on the brink of climate
catastrophe
um begs the question has anything been
achieved at cop27 no
yeah well I mean the fund for uh foreign
Nations to help with the impact of
climate change is certainly an
achievement it's something that
developing countries have been arguing
for for pretty much decades
um and with this devastating floods
we've seen in Pakistan uh it's obviously
vital that these countries have access
uh to funds so that you know they can
protect themselves from the horrible
consequences of climate change but with
that being said uh not having that firm
commitment on making sure warming stays
at a maximum of 1.5 degrees uh is
devastating and it's you know we're
compromising the future of our
grandchildren of our great grandchildren
but when you have players like Russia
when you have players like Saudi Arabia
who just frankly do not care I do wonder
what did they expect to come from this
did they expect a change of heart from
these brutal authoritarian leaders I
mean
thank you uh so much must leave it there
we've run out of time Noah and Sebastian
we shall see you in the next hour